FAVORITE BORDERLANDS STREAMERS
PLAYING THE GAME.
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN, THIS IS
BORDERLANDS 3.
[ MUSIC ]
>> GOOD MORNING, EVERYONE!
APPOMATTOX WELCOME TO THE
BORDERLANDS 3 GAMEPLAY REVEAL
EVENT.
PLEASE WELCOME TO THE STAGE
BORDERLANDS 3 CREATIVE DIRECTOR
PAUL SAGE.
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE] PLEASE
WELCOME TO THE STAGE, GEARBOX
SOFTWARE FOUNDER, ME!
RANDY PITCHFORD.
HOW IS IT GOING, GUYS?
THANK YOU FOR JOINING US HERE IN
HOLLYWOOD, CALIFORNIA.
AS WE SHARE BORDERLANDS 3
GAMEPLAY FOR THE VERY FIRST
TIME.
IT IS HARD TO BELIEVE THAT TEN
YEARS AGO, BORDERLANDS USHERED
IN THE SHOOTER LOOTER.
I MEAN, WHO WE ARE.
WE ARE ABOUT HERE TO EXPERIENCE
BORDERLANDS 3.
IT HAS BEEN ABOUT FIVE YEARS
SINCE THE GEARBOX SOFTWARE
DEVELOPER TEAM STARTED WORKING
ON THIS GAME.
WE ARE SO EXCITED TO BE HERE TO
SHARE IT WITH YOU TODAY.
>> NOW I KNOW THAT EVERYBODY IS
USED TO HEARING ME AND RANDY
SPEAK ON BEHALF OF THE TEAM,
TODAY, I WOULD LIKE TO INTRODUCE
YOU TO SOME OF THE REST OF THE
TALENT BEHIND BORDERLANDS.
>> THE BORDERLANDS 3 TEAM, YOU
GUYS!
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
>> THANK YOU, GUYS.
THESE DEVELOPERS ON STAGE
INCLUDE PEOPLE WHO HAVE BEEN
WITH FROM THE VERY BEGINNING
WHEN WE CREATED THE SHOOTER
LOOTER GENRE.
GREAT TALENT THAT HAS JOINED
WITH US ALONG THE WAY.
ALL OF US HERE HAVE BEEN WORKING
TOGETHER WITH OUR PEERS BACK IN
GEARBOX FRISCO HQ AND GEARBOX
STUDIO QUEBEC.
WE ARE THRILLED TO BE HERE TO
FINALLY SHARE OUR WORK.
IF YOU EVER ENJOYED A
BORDERLANDS GAME OR LOOKING
FORWARD TO BORDERLANDS 3, IF YOU
WILL INDULGE ME ONE MORE TIME,
SHOW THIS TEAM, THIS TALENT.
>> THEY WILL JOIN US IN A BIT.
EACH OF YOU WILL HAVE AN
OPPORTUNITY LATER TO GO HANDS-ON
WITH BORDERLANDS 3 AND THIS
TIME, WE WILL BE WITH YOU
HELPING YOU OUT.
THANK YOU, GUYS.
JEREMY, DEQUAN, COULD YOU STAY
BEHIND?
>> THEY WILL BE PLAYING.
RIGHT HERE.
I'M NOT SURE IF YOU HAVE BEEN TO
AN EVENT LIKE THIS BEFORE.
ALL OF THIS IS MADE POSSIBLE
BECAUSE OF OUR PUBLISHING
PARTNER 2K GAMES, AND SUPPORT
FROM HARDWARE PARTNER AMD
POWERED BY RIESSEN AND RADION.
WE HAVE INCREDIBLE [ EXPLETIVE ]
BY THEM.
WE WANTED TO PUT THAT AMD
HARDWARE TO THE TEST WITH A
POWERPOINT.
SO CAN WE START THE
PRESENTATION?
>> YEAH!
SO WE PREPARED A PRESENTATION ON
WHAT THE NEXT BORDERLANDS GAME
WILL BE.
>> YOU ARE LOOKING AT ENGINE
RENDERED IMAGE FROM THE VERY
BEGINNING OF BORDERLANDS 3.
LOOK AT THE ENVIRONMENT.
IT IS PANDORA.
THE ART.
THE STYLE.
THE GOAL WAS TO TRY TO CREATE AN
IMAGE THAT WAS FRESH BUT ALSO
FAMILIAR.
WE WANTED TO LOOK FORWARD AND
TAKE FULL ADVANTAGE OF TODAY'S
TECHNOLOGY IN A WAY THAT
RESPECTS THAT ONE OF A KIND ART
DIRECTION KNOWN THROUGHOUT THE
VIDEO GAME WORLD AS THE
BORDERLANDS ART STYLE.
>> OKAY.
LET'S BE HONEST, THIS ISN'T AN
ACTUAL SCREEN SHOT FROM THE
GAME.
WHAT YOU ARE LOOKING AT IS THE
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE] NOW WE
SKIPPED PAST THE LOGOS AND A LOT
OF THE INTRODUCTIONS BECAUSE WE
FELT THAT THE MOST HONEST WAY TO
BRING THE GAME TO YOU TODAY, WAS
TO START FROM THE VERY
BEGINNING.
SO WITH THAT, LET'S PLAY SOME
BORDERLANDS 3.
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
>> YOU MUST BE THE NEW RECRUIT.
I'M A STEWART BOT.
AND YOU CAN CALL ME GENERAL
CLAPTRAP OF THE CRIMSON RAIDERS.
WHAT IS YOUR NAME?
>> AMARA.
>> THANK YOU.
>> I'LL PREPARE YOUR TOMBSTONE
JUST IN CASE.
THOSE JERKS THAT TRY TO RUN YOU,
THE CHILDREN OF THE CULT.
ABANDONED CULT THAT FOLLOW THE
CREEPY LEADERS WITH BLIND
DEVOTION WHICH REMINDS ME, IF
YOU ARE GOING TO OBEY MY EVERY
BECKON CALL, YOU WILL NEED AN
ECHO DEVICE.
TRY IT OUT.
I RINSED IT OFF MYSELF.
THE ELKO 3.
SLIGHTLY MORE POWERFUL THAN THE
ECHO 2 AND TWICE AS EXPENSIVE.
BESIDES, THE ECHO 2 HAD A TINY
ISSUE WITH SPONTANEOUS
COMBUSTION.
NOW LISTEN UP, RECRUIT, LILITH
ORDERED US TO TAKE OVER THE
CHILDREN OF THE BULK PROPAGANDA
CENTER.
TRY TO SHOW THOSE KULTI WEIRDOES
THAT NO ONE MESSES WITH THE
CRIMSON RAIDERS.
FOLLOW ME TO GLORY!
>> SO LILITH ORDERED US TO TAKE
OVER THE RECRUITMENT CENTER OF
THE CHILDREN OF THE VAULT.
IN THE INTRODUCTION THAT WE
SKIPPED, YOU WOULD LEARN THAT
THE CHILDREN OF THE VAULT IS A
NEW CULT THAT HAS EMERGED ON
PANDORA.
SIREN LILITH AND THE CRIMSON
RAIDERS ARE RECRUITING NEW VAULT
HUNTER, THAT IS YOU, US, AND WE
ARE TO INVESTIGATE THE CHILDREN
OF THE VAULT CULT AND DISCOVER
WHO THEIR MYSTERIOUS LEADERS
ARE.
>> BEFORE WE REEK OUR RIGHTEOUS
VENGEANCE, REGISTER YOUR ECHO AT
THIS CHANGE.
ONCE WE DEFEAT THE CULT, I'LL BE
FAMOUS.
WHEN I AM SIGNING AUTOGRAPHS, I
NEED YOU LOOKING SHARP WHILE
DEFENDING ME FROM MY
FAN/STALKERS.
>> AS HERE, WE ARE PLAYING
AMARA.
A WARRIOR.
AS CLAPTRAP MENTIONED, QUICK
CHANGE, UP TO YOU HOW YOU WANT
YOUR CHARACTER TO LOOK.
YOU CAN CHANGE AMARA AND CHANGE
IT OBVIOUSLY.
LET'S KEEP PLAYING FOR NOW,
GUYS.
>> USER AGREEMENT?
BORING.
DON'T WORRY.
CORPORATIONS HAVE OUR BEST
INTEREST AT HEART.
THE PROPAGANDA CENTER IS THIS
WAY!
LOCK, ENGAGE.
THAT CAN'T BE HAPPENING.
THE ENTIRE MISSION IS RUINED.
THINK CLAPTRAP, YOU ARE GREAT,
POWERFUL AND PEOPLE ALWAYS DO
WHAT YOU TELL THEM TO.
THAT IS IT.
RECRUIT.
GET THAT GATE OPEN.
THIS IS AN ORDER FROM YOUR
SUPERIOR OFFICER.
>> SO OBVIOUSLY YOU ARE GETTING
A GLIMPSE HERE ON HOW WE USE THE
BEGINNING OF THE GAME TO MAKE
SURE THAT PLAYERS ARE UP TO
SPEED HOW FIRST PERSON VIDEO
GAMES WORK.
WE CAN VALIDATE THAT PLAYERS
UNDERSTAND HOW TO NAVIGATE THE
ENVIRONMENT AND INTERACT WITH
IT.
>> YOU DID IT!
BEST RECRUIT EVER!
DON'T GET COCKY.
>> WE'LL EVEN BE ABLE TO KNOW
HOW A PLAYER HAS LEARNED HOW TO
CROUCH AND HOW TO SLIDE.
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE] YOU HAVE
TO MAKE SURE THAT YOU CAN JUMP.
AND IF YOU MISS, THAT YOU CAN
MANTLE UP, CLIMB THE HIGHER
LEDGES.
>> THE PROPAGANDA CENTER IS UP
AHEAD.
THEY HAVE BEEN KILLING LEFT AND
RIGHT.
THEY TOTALLY SUCK SKAG BALLS.
I HAVE A FULL PROOF PLAN TO KICK
THEIR [ EXPLETIVE ].
>> WITH MOST GAMES, WE ARE USING
THE BEGIN TO TEACH THE
FUNDAMENTALS AND SETTING THE
TONE OF THE GAME.
RIGHT?
JUST LIKE OUR UNIQUE ART STYLE,
WE WANT PEOPLE TO FEEL RIGHT
AWAY WHAT WE BELIEVE HELPS
BORDERLANDS SPECIAL.
A STYLE OF WRITING THAT IS
RIVERRENCE AND GENUINE.
>> I HID A WEAPONS CASH NEARBY.
STAY QUIET AND FOLLOW MY EVERY
MOVE.
IT IS SEALTH TIME!
[ SINGING ]
PERFECT.
ONCE WE COMPLETE OUR MISSION,
LILITH HAS TO PROMOTE ME TO
SUPER GENERAL.
STAND BACK!
>> SO WE ARE THROWING SETH OUT
THE WINDOW?
>> RELAX, IT IS PANDORA, SUPER
WEIRD IF SOMETHING IS NOT
EXPLODING.
TAKE YOUR GUN, RECRUIT.
YOU WILL NEED IT.
THESE GUNS, LIKE MYSELF, AREN'T
BEHOLDEN TO PRIMARY FUNCTION.
I CAN DANCE.
AND SING.
♪ AND NOW SOME GUNS INCLUDE AN
ALTERNATE SHOOTING MODE  ♪
>> TRY IT OUT!
FOLLOW ME, RECRUIT.
>> ALL RIGHT.
IS CLAPTRAP JUST MENTIONED IN
ORDER TO STAY COMPETITIVE, SOME
OF OUR GUN MANUFACTURERS HAVE
ADDED ALTERNATE FIRING MODES.
IF WE LOOK HERE, WE CAN SEE THAT
WE HAVE A PISTOL.
IF WE FIRE REGULARLY, WE FIRE
BULLETS.
BUT IF WE SWITCH OUR ALTERNATE
FIRING MODES, WE FIRE OFF MICRO
MISSILES.
[APPLAUSE] NOW LATER IN THE
GAME, YOU WILL FIND GUNS THAT
CAN SWITCH BETWEEN ICE BULLETS
AND FIRE BULLETS OR YOU MIGHT
FIND GUNS THAT HAVE A CHAIN GUN
ON TOP, WHEN SWITCH FIRING
MODES, SHOOT GRENADES.
IT GETS CRAZY.
PLAYER WHOSE MAXIMIZE ALL FIRE
MODES, TWICE THE NUMBER OF GUNS
AVAILABLE THAN THEY HAD TO START
WITH.
>> WAIT HERE.
I WILL TALK MY WAY IN, BECOME
THEIR KING AND YOU WILL SURPRISE
SLAUGHTER THEM IN COLD BLOOD.
WATCH AND LEARN, RECRUIT.
HELLO!
ANYONE THERE?
>> THE INFLUENCER ON THE
CHILDREN OF THE VAULT.
WHAT DO YOU WANT BOT?
>> HELLO, BLOOD THIRSTY MANIAC.
IT IS I, CLAPTRAP, SLAYER OF THE
DESTROYER.
SUPER GENERAL OF THE CRIMSON
RAIDERS.
WE HAVE YOU COMPLETELY
SURROUNDED.
OPEN THE GATES NOW.
PERHAPS I WILL BE MERCIFUL.
>> OH, YEAH, LET ME THINK ABOUT
THAT.
>> THEY MIGHT CALL THEMSELVES
CHILDREN OF THE VAULT BUT STILL
BANDITS.
BANDITS ARE INCREDIBLY STUPID.
>> OKAY.
WE ARE GOING TO SURRENDER.
PLEASE DON'T KILL US.
>> THAT IS WHAT I THOUGHT.
OPEN THE DOORS IMMEDIATELY FOR
YOUR NEW KING.
>> EASY, EASY.
WE ARE COMING OUT.
JUST WAIT RIGHT THERE.
>> HE DID IT.
I DID IT.
ANOTHER VICTORY FOR THE CRIMSON
RAIDERS.
HEY, I FEEL FUNNY.
WHAT IS HAPPENING TO ME?
WHOA!
[INDISCERNIBLE]
>> SEE THE DEGRADING COVER.
>> LOOKIE WHAT WE GOT HERE!
>> OH, OH!
BORDERLANDS 3 IS RATED M FOR
MATURE, RIGHT?
>> PUT THESE BULLETS INTO THE
BAD GUY, RIGHTED?
>> YOU ARE GOING TO BE MY NEW
TEAM BOT.
I'M GOING TO GET IN YOUR HEAD.
>> WHOA!
REGROUP!
>> I KNOW CLAPTRAP CAN BE A
LITTLE CLAPTRAP BUT HE IS STILL
ONE OF US.
WE ARE GOING TO HAVE TO SAVE
HIM.
I'LL BE THERE SOON.
>> SO LET'S SEE IF WE CAN FIND
SOME LOOT.
I SAW OVER HERE NEAR THAT DOOR,
I SAW A RED CHEST.
IT LOOKS LIKE A TRUNK OF A CAR.
WHAT DO WE GOT HERE?
WHAT ELSE IS THERE?
OH, THAT IS INTERESTING.
>> ALL RIGHT.
SO WE CAN SEE THAT THIS WEAPON
HAS HIGH ACCURACY, HIGHER
HANDLING, LET'S LOOK AT THE
OTHER ONE.
ALL RIGHT.
THIS WEAPON HAS HIGHER DAMAGE
AND HIGHER RELOAD TIME.
IT IS FINESSE OR BRUTE FORCE IN
THIS CASE.
>> WHAT DO YOU GUYS THINK?
SHOOT FROM THE HIP OR BAD [
EXPLETIVE ] SCOPE?
I THINK THAT YOU GUYS SAID
SCOPE.
YOU KNOW WHAT?
TAKE BOTH OF THEM.
WE WILL TRY THE SCOPE AND THEN
WE WILL SWITCH.
THAT IS PRETTY BAD [ EXPLETIVE
].
THESE ARE LIKE LEVEL ONE GUNS,
TOO.
>> OVER HERE!
>> OH!
>> OIL IS FLAMMABLE.
>> THERE IS NO WAY WITH YOUR
DELICATE BODY CAN SURVIVE A
SHOWDOWN.
LOOK AROUND FOR A SHIELD!
>> OKAY.
WE NEED A SHIELD.
THIS IS AN AREA MISSION.
IF WE LOOK AROUND, WE SHOULD BE
ABLE TO FIND SOME SOMEWHERE.
NOT IN THE SKAG PILE.
>> DEQUAN, YOU ON THIS?
ALL RIGHT.
>> THAT LOOKS PROMISING.
THERE WE GO.
77.
105, THAT IS BETTER.
TAKE THAT ONE.
>> IT JUST MIGHT KEEP HIM FROM
KILLING YOU IN ONE HIT.
LET'S GET YOU IN THERE RECRUIT.
HEY!
ALL YOUR DUMB FRIENDS ARE DEAD!
I CHALLENGE YOU TO A TRIAL BY
COMBAT!
BUT BECAUSE I'M STUCK WITH THIS,
MY ROYAL SHALL TAKE ISSUE
INSTEAD.
>> COME ON IN.
I HAVEN'T MET MY SACRIFICE QUOTA
FOR THE DAY!
>> SO I KNOW THAT YOU GUYS ARE
GETTING AHEAD OF ME.
YOU KNOW WHAT IS COMING NEXT.
THIS IS OUR FIRST MINI BOSS
FIGHT.
DEQUAN, YOU READY?
WE ARE FLYING WITHOUT A NET
HERE.
NO GOD MODE.
SO LET'S DO IT.
[LAUGHTER]
>> NICE!
>> OH!
[APPLAUSE]
>> MY GOD!
THAT WAS AWESOME.
>> SCORE ONE FOR THE CRIMSON
RAIDERS.
YOU AND CLAPTRAP SECURE THE
AREA.
I'M ON MY WAY.
>> THIS GAME IS DYNAMIC,
DIFFERENT EVERY TIME THEY PLAY
IT.
THAT WAS THE BEST KILL EVER.
I'M GLAD YOU GOT TO SEE THAT.
LOOK AT THAT.
>> RECRUIT, ARE YOU DEAD?
IF NOT, GET ME DOWN!
THE CONTROLS ARE ON THE SECOND
FLOOR.
>> NOW YOU'LL NOTICE THAT DEQUAN
PICKED UP THE SHOTGUN THAT SHIV
DROPPED.
WE THINK THAT IT IS IMPORTANT
THAT MOMENT OF VICTORY SHOULD
HAVE A SUBSEQUENT REWARD AT THAT
MOMENT.
SO OF COURSE, YOU CAN PICK UP
GEAR RIGHT AWAY.
>> ALL RIGHT, DUDE.
DEQUAN HAS THE SAME AFFLICTION I
HAVE, YOU HAVE TO OPEN EVERY
SINGLE FRICKEN' CHEST.
THIS IS A DEMO.
ALL RIGHT.
IT IS SO TEMPT, THOSE GREEN
LIGHTS.
OH, CLAPTRAP IS NAGGING AT US
ALREADY.
IT IS NOT A BORDERLANDS GAME
UNLESS CLAPTRAP TRUMPS BETWEEN
NEEDY, BOSSY AND PATHETIC.
I DON'T KNOW HOW YOU FEEL ABOUT
IT, I STILL KIND OF LOVE
CLAPTRAP.
LET'S HELP HIM OUT.
THIS BORDERLANDS 3, YOU CAN
REVIVE MPC'S AND MPC'S CAN
REVIVE YOU!
LET'S HELP OUT CLAPTRAP.
>> FOCUS!
WOW!
I DID IT.
I SINGLE HANDILY TAKE ON THE CMV
AND SENT THEM PACKING.
ALL THAT IS LEFT IS SIGNAL
LILITH THAT THE MISSION IS
COMPLETE.
[APPLAUSE]
>> LILITH, I CAN SAFELY REPORT
THAT OPERATION IS A COMPLETE
SUCCESS.
I DID IT ALL BY MYSELF.
>> I'LL BET.
WELL, THE CULT HAS DESTROYED
EVERY OTHER CRIMSON RAIDER
STRONGHOLD.
THIS WILL HAVE TO DO FOR NOW.
SO WHAT'S YOUR NAME, KILLER?
>> I AM AMARA.
NICE TATTOO SIREN SISTER.
YOU MUST BE THE VOICE IN MY
HEAD.
>> YEAH, ABOUT THAT, NOT THE
WEIRDEST THING YOU WILL SEE ON
PANDORA.
BUT SERIOUSLY, THANKS FOR
ANSWERING HI CALL.
WE MIGHT NOT HAVE THE NUMBERS
BUT WITH A BAD [ EXPLETIVE ]
LIKE YOU, WE HAVE A FIGHTING
CHANCE.
WELCOME TO THE CRIMSON RAIDERS.
>> HEY, DO YOU HEAR BLOOD
THIRSTY SCREAMING?
>> MORE COV.
LET'S SEE WHAT YOU GOT, RECRUIT.
>> IT IS THE FIRE HAWK!
>> WATCH IT!
>> YOU'RE ON THE WRONG TEAM [
EXPLETIVE ].
>> SHE IS PRETTY RAD.
>> NICE FIGHTING, KILLER.
>> SO WE ARE GOING TO SKIP AHEAD
FOR A MINUTE.
I WANT YOU TO CONSIDER WHAT WE
HAVE LEARNED SO FAR.
YOU ARE A NEW VAULT HUNTER AND
YOU JUST JOINED LILITH AND THE
CRIMSON RAIDERS.
OUR ENEMIES ON PANDORA ARE A
FANATICAL CULT CALLED THE
CHILDREN OF THE VAULT.
FROM HERE, YOU AND LILITH WILL
FIGHT SIDE BY SIDE TO CAPTURE
THE RECRUITING CENTER THAT
LILITH BELIEVES SHE CAN RECOVER
A KEY THAT WILL LEAD HER TO FIND
VAULTS ON OTHER WORLDS.
THE HUNT WILL EVENTUALLY LEAD US
HERE TO THE HOLY BROADCAST
CENTER WHERE A FEARSOME BANDIT
BOSS, MOUTHPIECE, BROADCAST
PROPAGANDA TO THE CHILDREN OF
THE VAULT ALL OVER PANDORA.
WHICH ARE HERE TO INVADE THE
HOLY RECRUIT MANY CENTER, FACE
MOUTHPIECE AND LIBERATE THE KEY
TO THE VAULT.
>> LIKE RANDY MENTIONED, WE
SKIPPED AHEAD IN THE STORY, IF
YOU NOTICE, WE SKIPPED AHEAD IN
LEVELS.I WANT TO TAKE THE TIME
TO SHOW YOU THE SKILLS IN
BORDERLANDS 3.
SO WHEN YOU FIRST GET YOUR
SKILLS IN BORDERLANDS 3, YOU
DON'T HAVE ONE ACTION SKILL
AVAILABLE TO YOU, YOU HAVE ALL
THREE ACTION SKILLS AVAILABLE TO
YOU AT THE MOMENT YOU OPEN IT
UP.
SO THEN, WHAT YOU DO, YOU QUIP
ONE OF YOUR ACTION SKILLS.
YOU WANT TO TAKE A LOOK AT THE
ACTION SKILLS?
SO THIS FIRST ONE, IT IS
PHASEGRASS, WILL BE REMINISCENT
OF MAYA, CONTROL THE BATTLEFIELD
IN LIFTING ENEMIES UP TO THE
AIR.
THE NEXT ONE HERE IS PHASECAST.
AND PHASELAM, IT IS AN AREA OF
EFFECT THAT COMES OUT AROUND
AMARA AND DESTROYS ENEMIES AND
KNOCKS THEM BACK.
AS YOU PROGRESS, ONCE YOU PICK
YOUR ACTION SKILL AND QUIP IT,
ALSO OPEN UP AUGMENTATIONS THAT
ALLOW YOU TO FURTHER CUSTOMIZE
THAT ACTION SKILL.
MAXIMIZE THE SKILL OF YOUR
CHARACTER.
WE WORKED HARD THAT EACH OF THE
FOUR CHARACTERS ARE COMPLETELY
UNIQUE.
EVEN WITHIN EACH CHARACTER,
HUNDREDS OF MEANINGFUL OPTIONS.
IF TWO PEOPLE WANT TO TEAM UP
AND PLAY THE SAME CHARACTER,
VERY LIKELY HAVE COMPLETELY
DIFFERENT CAPABILITIES.
>> YOU READY TO GO?
>> LET'S DO IT.
>> LEVEL UP.
ALL RIGHT.
LEVELED UP.
>> ONE THING TO LOOK OUT FOR,
LOOK AT THE DAMAGE NUMBERS THAT
COME UP OFF THE ENEMIES.
WE'LL USE SOME OF THE
INFORMATION LATER.
LOOK AT NUMBER, 56, 26.
>> 26 IS THERE.
>> OH.
>> NOW THAT IS A HIGH PERIOD
SHOTGUNS.
HIGH PERIOD SHOTGUNS HAVE
SHIELDS THAT COME OUT.
>> SWITCH BACK TO THE SHOTGUN.
[ MUSIC ]
>> IT IS A NEW ELEMENT TYPE,
RADIATION.
>> HIT CRITICAL MASS.
>> AT THE RADIATED ENEMY DIE, HE
WILL EXPLODE AND RADIATE THE
ENEMIES AROUND HIM.
>> OKAY.
[ LAUGHTER ]
>> THAT IS MAYHEM.
I THINK THAT HE CLEANED THIS
AREA UP.
LET'S SEE WHAT KIND OF LOOT WE
CAN FIND.
THAT IS AN OUTHOUSE BUT A GREEN
LIGHT.
SOME GOOD STUFF.
LET'S SEE HERE.
SO AMARA'S LEVEL 5, THESE
WEAPONS ARE LEVEL 5.
I WANT YOU TO NOTICE THAT,
NOTICE THE TWO HERE.
WE HAVE A RARE AND EPIC.
BOTH LEVEL 5.
AND THE REASON I WANT YOU TO
REMEMBER THAT, IS BECAUSE THAT
WAS KIND OF A CHALLENGING FIGHT.
WE ARE GOING TO NEED SOME HELP
FOR THE NEXT SECTION.
WE WILL BRING THIS A CO-OP
BUDDY.
CO-OP PLAYABLE, SPLIT SCREEN,
NETWORK, HOWEVER YOU WOULD LIKE
TO PLAY.
AMARA PICKED UP THE PURPLE.
LET'S TURNAROUND AND FIND OUR
CO-OP BUDDY.
THIS IS ZANE FLYNT.
THE OPERATIVE.
WE WILL SWITCH TO ZANE'S VIEW.
CAN WE FLIP THAT?
I WANT YOU TO NOTICE SOMETHING
HERE.
ZANE IS LEVEL 25.
OBVIOUSLY ZANE HAS BEEN PLAYING
LONGER THAN AMARA THAT IS LEVEL
5.
IF WE LOOK AT ZANE'S LOOT, HE
HAS HIS OWN INSTANCE OF LOOT.
WHAT IS GOING ON HERE?
THIS IS CALLED LOOT INSTANCING,
IT IS A NEW OPTIONAL FEATURE IN
BORDERLANDS 3.
IT ALLOWS EACH COOPERATIVE
PLAYER TO HAVE THEIR OWN
INSTANCE OF LOOT.
INSTANCE LOOT IS HELPFUL FOR
PLAYERS THAT WANT TO PLAY
COOPERATIVELY BUT DON'T WANT TO
COMPETE FOR THE LOOT THAT DROPS.
NOTHING WORSE THAN GETTING ON
LEAN WITH RANDOMS AND A LOOT
NINJA IN THE GROUP, RIGHT?
INSTANCE LOOT SOLVES THAT
PROBLEM FOR PLAYERS THAT WANT TO
USE IT.
THE OTHER FEATURE THAT
COMPLEMENTS THIS IS LEVEL
BALANCING.
NOTICE HOW ZANE'S LOOT IS NOT
ONLY INSTANCED, BUT IT IS
ACTUALLY BALANCED FOR HIS LEVEL.
THAT MEANS THE LOOT, THE
ENEMIES, EVERYTHING
AUTOMATICALLY BALANCES TO THE
LEVEL OF THE PLAYER SO THAT
EVERYONE HAS A GOOD TIME.
AND MY COI DON'T KNOW GROUP,
SOME OF US WOULD GET AHEAD OF
THE OTHER, RIGHT?
THEN BACK TOGETHER, OUT OF
WHACK.
WITH INSTANCE LOOT AND THIS MODE
OF GAMEPLAY, EVERYTHING BALANCES
OUT.
>> NOW, THAT IS OKAY.
AND YOU CAN CLAP IF YOU WOULD
LIKE.
[ APPLAUSE ]
NOW THERE ARE STILL SOME OF US
WHO ACTUALLY LIKE COMPETING FOR
LOOT OR BRINGING IN OVERPOWERED
CHARACTERS TO HELP LEVEL UP THE
LOWER LEVEL CHARACTERS.
FOR THOSE WHO ARE LIKE THAT, WE
CAN ASSURE YOU THAT THERE IS
STILL A MODE FOR YOU IN
BORDERLANDS 3.
IT IS CALLED CLASSIC MODE.
[APPLAUSE]
>> THAT IS RIGHT.
NOW THAT WE HAVE SEEN ZANE THE
OPERATIVE, LET'S HAVE A LOOK AT
WHAT HE CAN DO.
ZANE IS LEVEL 25.
WE EQUIPPED A LOT OF ACTION
SKILLS AND SKILL POINTS HERE.
YOU WANT TO WALK US THROUGH
THIS, PAUL IN.
>> LET'S DO THIS.
THE FIRST SKILL WE HAVE IS DING
DALE DIGICLONE.
IT WILL SHOOT GUNS AS WELL.
MY FAVORITE FEATURE, TELEPORT TO
DIGICLONE AND SWAP PLACES.
THIS IS DRONE THAT WILL THREE
OUT OR WEAKEN THE ENEMIES OR USE
GRENADES IF YOU HAVE GRENADE
MODE EQUIPPED.
AND THEN WE HAVE THE BARRIER
SKILL.
NOW ZANE WILL THROW OUT A
BARRIER IN FRONT OF IT AND BLOCK
INCOMING BULLETS AND THINGS LIKE
THAT.
ONE OF THE COOLEST FEATURE, IF
YOUR TEAM OR ZANE IS AROUND
THIS, CONFIRM BENEFITS LIKE
HEALING, EVEN IF YOU HIRE
THROUGH IT, ADD ELEMENTAL TYPES
TO THAT.
NOW PROBABLY MY FAVORITE FEATURE
OF ZANE IS THE FACT THAT ZANE
CAN USE TWO ACTION SKILLS AT ONE
TIME.
>> THAT IS RIGHT.
[ APPLAUSE ]
>> IF YOU THINK ABOUT IT, IF YOU
THINK ABOUT ZANE, RIGHT?
HE HAS HIS BARRIER, WHICH IS
KIND OF LIKE THE SOLDIER CLASS'S
CAPABILITY.
HE HAS THE SENTINEL WHICH IS
LIKE MORDECAI BLOOD WING BUT
HYPED UP FROM THAT.
HE HAS THE DIGICLONE, LIKE OUR
SKILL FROM BORDERLANDS 2.
HE IS LIKE A SOLDIER, ASSASSIN
WRAPPED UP IN ONE.
ALL RIGHT.
WE HAVE AMARA, ZANE, WE KNOW
WHAT THEY CAN DO.
LET'S GET INTO THE HOLY
BROADCAST CENTER TO TO SEE IF WE
CAN FIND MOUTHPIECE.
>> OOPSY.
LOOKS LIKE WE HAVE A TECHNICAL
ISSUE.
DON'T WORRY.
WE'LL POST THE WELCOME BID LATER
ALONG WITH SOME NEW, LET'S PLAY.
SIGNING OFF FOR NOW.
DON'T FORGET TO LIKE, FOLLOW AND
OBEY.
>> ANOTHER PERFECT LIVE STREAM
FROM OUR INFALLIBLE GOD QUEEN
TYREEN.
THE HOLY BROADCASTER OPENS ONCE
AGAIN TO HEAR YOUR SINS AND
RECEIVE YOUR SKINS!
>> OUCH!
>> TYREEN!
>> WHEW!
STILL GOT IT!
>> THESE ARE THE EMBARKING
TARGETS FOR THE SENTINEL.
ALSO CHECK OUT THE DAMAGE
NUMBERS, RIGHT?
HIS ENEMIES ARE LEVEL 27.
BUT HIS DAMAGE IS DOWN TO
AMARA'S GAME.
BECAUSE HE IS IN AMARA'S GAME
RIGHT NOW.
FOR AMARA, THOSE ENEMIES ARE
LEVEL 5.
ALL RIGHT.
WE CLEAN THIS AREA UP.
LET'S SEE IF WE CAN FIND SOME
LOOT.
OKAY.
NOW ONCE AGAIN, BEING HONEST,
YOU KNOW, TO SHOW THE BREAD OF
GUN, SOME OF THE BREAD.
WE CHEATED AND ADDED SOME CHESTS
WITH BETTER WEAPONS.
>> THAT RED CHEST WON'T BE IN
THE GAME YOU PLAY.
WE ADDED THAT FOR THIS PURPOSE.
IT IS OKAY.
THERE ARE PLENTY OF RED CHESTS.
YOU'LL BE FIND.
WE'LL FEED YOU BABY BERDS.
WE WANTED TO SHOW YOU SOME TEDO,
INSTEAD OF RELOADING, YOU THROW
THEM AWAY.
WHEN YOU THROW AWAY THEM IN
BORDERLANDS 3, SOME CRAZY [
EXPLETIVE ] CAN HAPPEN.
GUNS WITH LEGS.
LET'S SEE SOME OTHER OPTIONS.
WHAT DOES THIS ONE DO?
WE PICKED SOME DISTRICT OF [IND]
WEAPONS, AND GO INTO THE FIGHT.
>> WE AREN'T GOING TO LEARN.
KEEPING THOSE SPEAKERS.
>> OH, IT IS ADORABLE.
>> YOU CAN SEE THAT ONE MERV'S
ROCKETS OUT.
>> THROW A MERV GUN OUT.
CHECK THIS OUT.
CALMING ROCKETS.
THAT WAS A LITTLE CLOSE TO THE
EARS.
>> OH, GOODBYE.
>> ALL RIGHT.
AND YOU GUYS READY?
OH, YOU LEARNED!
WE CAN DODGE THAT.
>> THAT IS WICKED.
I SEE SOME AMMUNITION VENDING
MACHINES.
WALK UP TO THAT AMMO VENDING
MACHINE.
I WANT TO SHOW YOU THIS.
HE IS ALREADY FULL ON AMMO.
YOU JUST PRESS Y RIGHT THERE AND
RELOAD ALL OF THE AMMO.
YOU DON'T HAVE TO GO IN AND BUY
THINGS ONE AT A TIME.
[ APPLAUSE ]
OF COURSE, YOU CAN BUY
INDIVIDUAL PIECES IF YOU WANT.
NOW, I DON'T KNOW ABOUT YOU GUY,
WHEN YOU PLAY A VIDEO GAME AND
HAPPEN UPON A ROOM WHERE THERE
IS AMMO AND VENDING MACHINES TO
MAKE SURE THAT YOU ARE STOCKED
UP, YOU ARE A SAFE BET THAT YOU
ARE ABOUT TO RUN INTO A BOSS
FIGHT.
NOT ONLY BORDERLANDS A A MUCH,
MUCH LARGER GAME THAN BEFORE IT,
MORE BOSS FIGHTS THAN EVER
BEFORE.
WE THINK BOSS FIGHTS ARE
EXCITING OPPORTUNITY FOR PLAYERS
TO HAVE SKILL TESTED AND
REWARDED WITH KICK [ EXPLETIVE ]
LOOT.
LET'S GO AHEAD AND SEE IF WE CAN
FIND MOUTHPIECE.
>> ALL RIGHT.
[ MUSIC ]
>> YOU WILL DIE!
>> THIS SHIELDS LIKE AN
EQUALIZER.
ZANE USED HIS TELEPORT TO DODGE
THAT AREA OF EFFECT THAT
MOUTHPIECE JUST MADE.
OH [ EXPLETIVE ].
>> IS THAT ALL YOU GOT?
OH!
>> OH, GOD.
YOU NEED IT.
>> YOU HAVE TO LOOK AT THE LOOT,
MAN.
SOME LOOT OVER THERE.
>> GET THE LOOT.
>> DID YOU SEE THE GUN THAT
MOUTHPIECE WAS SHOOTING AT US
WITH SOUND WAVES FLYING OUT?
CHECK THIS OUT.
[APPLAUSE] ONE OF THE GREATEST
FEELINGS IN BORDERLANDS IS WHEN
AN ENEMY IS USING A GUN AGAINST
YOU, YOU KILL THAT GUY AND TAKE
THAT GUN AND USE IT AGAINST YOUR
NEXT ONE.
I LOVE THAT SO MUCH.
>> WELL, LET'S DO WHAT WE CAME
HERE FOR.
LET'S GET THE VAULT MAP.
>> AMARA WILL YOU PICK THAT UP?
>> HAVE YOU COME ALL THIS WAY
WITH THAT BUSTED [ EXPLETIVE ]
MAP?
OR SEE ME?
I DIDN'T KNOW YOU WERE A SUPER
FAN.
AND YOU MISSED THE SHOW.
WHAT IS UP WITH THE HUGS?
IT IS A THING I DO.
CHECK OUT THE SCREENS.
SO I OFFERED THE SONS MATCHES A
PLACE IN MY FAMILY BUT THEY JUST
WANTED GUNS AND CATCH.
THEY BETRAYED THE FAMILY.
THEN, SAID SOMETHING GREAT.
>> GODS DON'T NEGOTIATE.
>> GODS DON'T NEGOTIATE?
I LOVE IT!
LOVE IT!
LIKE I SAID, THAT MAP IS SUPER
BUSTED.
GO AHEAD AND TAKE IT.
I'LL SWING BY LATER TO PICK IT
UP.
YOU ARE MY MOST LOYAL FOLLOWER
VAULT.
AND YOU JUST DON'T KNOW IT YET.
>> SO YOU HAVE JUST MET TRY AND
TYREEN KAL CALYPSO.
THE CALYPSO TWINS.
WE LEARNED EARLIER ON PANDORA, A
CULT CALLED CHILDREN OF THE
VAULT.
EVERY CULT NEEDS LEADERS.
THIS VAULT IS LED BY THE KAL CAO
TWINS.
CULT OF PERSONALITY AROUND
THEMSELVES.
YOU KNOW THE TYPE OF STREAMERS
WE ARE TALKING ABOUT.
THE KIND OF STREAMERS EVERYBODY
HATES.
THESE ARE THE DOUCHEY STREAMERS
OF THE IMPOSSIBLE FUTURE, THAT
YOU CAN POSSIBLY IMAGINE.
AS TYREEN IMAGINED, ABILITY TO
LEECH POWER FROM ANY LIVING
THING.
HER AIM TO USE THE CULT TO LEAD
HER TO THE VAULTS TO SOAK UP THE
POWER OF THE VAULT MONSTERS.
WE ARE VAULT HUNTERS.
WE CAN'T ALLOW HAD HER TO BEAT
US IN THE PRIZE.
WE ARE NOW IN A RACE TO FIND THE
VAULT HIDDEN IN OTHER WORLDS
THROUGHOUT THE GALAXY.
IN OTHER WORDS, WHEN WE GO TO
THE OTHER WORLDS WE ARE GOING TO
NEED A RIDE.
RIGHT?
SO LATER IN OUR VENTURE ON
PANDORA, WE WILL FIND A
SPACESHIP.
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE] I WOULD
LIKE TO INTRODUCE SANCTUARY.
WE DON'T TALK ABOUT SANCTUARY 2.
SINCE SANCTUARY 3 IS OUR HOME
BASE IT IS A GREAT STOPPING
POINT BETWEEN MISSIONS.
ON SANCTUARY 3 WE MEET OUR
FRIEND, TRADE OUR LOOT AND
PREPARE OURSELVES FOR WHAT COMES
NEXT.
YOU'LL NOTICE HERE, THERE IS A
QUICK CHANGE STATION WHERE WE
CAN MODIFY OUR APPEARANCE.
BUT THERE IS A NEW VENDING
MACHINE HERE ON THE RIGHT.
THIS IS SORT OF A SPACE LOST AND
FOUND.
HAVE YOU GUYS EVER LOST LOOT IN
BORDERLANDS?
LIKE A PURPLE OR A LEGENDARY
LANDS, SOMEPLACE WE CAN'T REACH?
WE COLLECT ALL OF THAT LOST LOOT
FOR YOU, AND DELIVER IT HERE FOR
YOU.
YOU WILL NEVER LOSE LOOT AGAIN.
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE] ALL RIGHT.
SO LET'S TALK ABOUT THIS.
THIS IS YOUR PLAYER QUARTERS.%
BECAUSE WE ARE PLAYING AMARA
RIGHT NOW, ALL OF THE DECORATION
AND EVERYTHING BILL AROUND
AMARA.
YOU CAN PLACE THINGS LIKE THIS
GUN, WE HAVE A TORRID PISTOL
HERE.
>> PRETTY RAD.
>> YOU CAN MODIFY THE PLAYER
QUARTERS HOW YOU WANT TO PLAY.
>> SINCE WE PICKED UP A PISTOL,
WE WILL TAKE IT WITH US ON A
TOUR AROUND SANCTUARY.
AND WHY DON'T WE STOP FIRST,
LET'S HEAD TO MARCUS, KEEP
GOING.
IGNORE THAT GOLDEN CHEST.
MARCUS'S PLACE IS RIGHT AROUND
THE CORNER HERE.
>> OH, IT IS A BEAUTIFUL DAY.
FULL OF OPPORTUNITY.
>> NOW BORDERLANDS 3 MARCUS WILL
BE VENDOR FOR YOWP GRADES TO THE
-- UPGRADES TO STORAGE DECK
UNIT.
MORE STORAGE TO CARRY MORE LOOT
AND MORE AMMUNITION.
>> YOU WILL NOTICE THAT IT COST
CASH TO UPGRADE YOUR STORAGE.
>> MARCUS ALSO HAS A SHOOTING
RANGE BACK THERE, IF YOU WANT TO
GET YOUR SKILLS UP, PRACTICE
WITH ANY INTERESTING NEW GUNS
YOU FOUND, YOU CAN DO THAT.
>> WHAT IS GOING ON BOW HUNTER?
>> WE ARE GOING TO TAKE A LOOK
AROUND THIS PLACE.
ISN'T THAT COOL?
THIS MAP CHANGED HANDS MORE THAN
ANY OTHER ONE.
TALENTED WORLD BUILDERS WANTED
TO GET THEIR HANDS ON THIS AND
MAKE IT GREAT.
IT IS NOT A PUB UNTIL YOU HAVE A
MOXXIE'S BAR, RIGHT?
[APPLAUSE]
>> THE NAME IS MOXXIE.
WHAT IS YOUR'S SUGAR?
THANKS FOR THE HELP SUGAR.
COME BACK.
>> LET'S TRY IT.
>> YEP.
ALL RIGHT.
>> THAT IS NOT GOOD.
>> NO.
>> BAD LUCK.
>> WELL, THANKS FOR ENCOURAGING
THAT.
>> LET'S KEEP GOING ON THE TOUR.
I LOVE SANCTUARY.
IT IS JUST SUCH A BEAUTIFUL, I
DON'T KNOW, THE LEVEL, I DIDN'T
WORK ON THIS ONE THAT MUCH, BUT
HELP GUIDE SOME OF IT.
BUT THE GUYS THAT DID THE ART
FOR THIS, ABSOLUTELY STUNNING.
THESE ARE THE JOKES.
>> YOU'RE UP LATE.
>> GOOD EVENING!
KNOCK, KNOCK.
ANYONE HOME?
>> JUST A MOMENT.
ALMOST THERE.
OH!
WHEW!
SURPRISINGLY COMFORTABLE, YOU
KNOW.
LIKE SLUSHY SLEEPING BAG.
ALTHOUGH I FEEL A BIT VISCOUS.
>> SO TANNIS IS BACK.
LET'S GO HEAD UP TO THE BRIDGE.
>> ALL RIGHT.
>> HEY PAUL.
>> YES, RANDY?
>> WHAT CAN WE DO ON THE BRIDGE?
>> SO FOR THE FIRST TIME EVER,
WE CAN LEAVE THE PANDORA SYSTEM.
>> YOU CAN SEE PANDORA IN THERE,
IN THE DISTANCE.
>> WHAT'S UP, KILLER?
ALL RIGHT.
LET'S GET TO IT.
>> WE ARE IN ORBIT AROUND
PANDORA RIGHT NOW.
WE'LL CHECK IT OUT BRIEFLY
BEFORE WE TAKE OFF.
YOU CAN SEE THE DISTINCTIVE
MERIDIAN SCAR.
BUT WITH THE SPACESHIP LIKE
SANCTUARY 3, WE CAN VISIT OTHER
WORLDS.
NOW THIS IS EARLY IN THE GAME.
SO WE HAVEN'T UNLOCKED A LOT OF
THE OTHER PLACES THAT YOU WILL
GET TO EXPLORE.
BUT FOR NOW, WE ARE GOING TO DO
INTERSTELLAR FAST TRAVEL TO PROM
ETHEA.
>> I ARRIVED IN ONE PIECE.
[ APPLAUSE ]
>> WE'LL GO DOWN TO PROMETHEA IN
A MOMENT AND MAKE OUR WAY TO THE
DOCKING BAY IN ORDER TO DO THAT.
IN BORDERLANDS YOU WILL BE ABLE
TO GO BACK AND FORTH FROM
PROMETHEA AND PANDORA AND ALL OF
THE OTHER WORLDS YOU DISCOVER
THROUGHOUT THE GAME.
>> MIGHT EVEN FIND A FEW
FAMILIAR FACES HERE.
>> WHAT'S UP BAD [ EXPLETIVE ]?
>> I LOVE MAYA'S LOOK.
SHE IS FULLY JEDI 'ED OUT.
WE'LL TAKE A COUPLE OTHER STOPS
ON THE WAY DOWN TO THE HANGER,
CONTINUE OUR TOUR OF SANCTUARY
3.
OH, YEAH, LET'S GO TO
HAMMERLOCKS.
>> HERE AT HAMMERLOCKS, ONE OF
THE COOL THINGS IS THAT
HAMMERLOCK ASKS YOU TO KILL
DIFFERENT CREATURES.
THIS IS A TROPHY ROOM FOR
KILLING THE CREATURES.
>> OH, IT IS YOU.
APOLOGIES, IT IS DARK AND I
NEVER ACTUALLY CLEANED THIS
MOLECULE.
>> YOU CAN SEE ALL OF THE TROPHY
MOUNTS ON THE WALL IS EMPTY.
WHICH MEANS WE HAVE WORK TO DO.
>> LOT OF WORK TO DO.
>> YOU ARE IN THE SHIP, YOU CAN
SEE THAT WE HAVE SHORT CUTS
BUILT IN.
>> THE MORE TIME YOU SPEND ON
PROMETHEA, THE MORE FAMILIAR YOU
WILL GET TO IT.
WE ENGINEERED SHORT CUTS AND
FIND YOUR WAY AROUND AND WHAT
YOU NEED PRETTY QUICKLY.
>> HOW IS YOUR DAY GOING?
>> HI THERE, SUGAR BOOTS.
>> ELLIE IS SHIP MECHANIC.
SHE RUNS THE CARGO BAY.
DOWN HERE, WE CAN CHECK OUT
VEHICLES WE COLLECTED.
WE CAN ALSO GET ACCESS TO THE
PLANETS WHEN WE ARE IN ORBIT.
WE ALSO HAVE SOME STOL AWAYS
THAT WE CAN MEET.
>> WHAT YOU WANT?
COME BACK, NEVER!
>> I THINK THAT VENDING MACHINE
THERE SAID VETERAN ON IT.
[LAUGHTER]
>> DON'T LOOK AT ME LIKE THAT.
I'M DOING ALL OF THE REAL WORK
HERE.
>> AND HE LOCKED US OUT.
>> I THINK THAT HE IS BUILDING A
GIRLFRIEND.
>> I CAN'T BELIEVE THAT CLAPTRAP
IS LONELY.
IT IS HARD TO BELIEVE.
SO WE ARE GOING TO HEAD TO THE
DROP POD HERE.
THIS WILL HELP US GET DOWN TO
PROMETHEA, IN FACT, WHY NOT SKIP
AHEAD A LITTLE BIT.
RATHER THAN START AT THE
BEGINNING OF PROMETHEA, WE CAN
JUMP FORWARD, A BUNCH OF LEVELS
AND I WANT TO SHOW YOU EXCITING
ACTION HERE.
IN THIS, PROMETHEA IS THE ATLAS
OF THE CORPORATION.
YOU WILL NOTICE THAT ATLAS IS
UNDER SIEGE BY MALLAWAN AND
PRIVATE ARMY.
IN BORDERLANDS, IN THIS
UNIVERSE, WHEN A CORPORATION
ATTEMPTS A HOSTILE TAKEOVER,
THEY DO IT WITH FULL MILITARY
GRADES FOR.
>> NOW BEFORE WE START, I WANT
YOU TO TAKE A LOOK AT THE GUN WE
ARE USING HERE.
THIS IS AN ATLAS PISTOL.
NOW THE COOL THING ABOUT AN
ATLAS PISTOL IS THAT IT HAS ALT
FIRE MODE THAT FIRES OUT A
TRACKING DART.
WHEN YOU FIRE THE TRACKING DART,
IT MARKS THE TARGET.
EVERY BULLET YOU FIRE
SUBSEQUENTLY WILL HIT THAT
TARGET.
LIKE THE FIFTH ELEMENT GUN.
>> FINALLY.
[APPLAUSE] SO LET ME INTRODUCE
OUR DEMOS, WE HAVE CHRIS PLAYING
AS ZANE.
ZANE IS CO-OP BUDDY THIS TIME.
PAUL IS PLAYING AS AMARA WHICH
IS WHAT IS ON SCREEN FOR US TO
WATCH.
YOU NOTICE AMARA AND ZANE ARE AT
LEVEL 10.
WE HAVE ACTUALLY SET THEM UP
WITH MICROPHONES SO THAT WE CAN
LISTEN IN ON CHATTER AS THEY
PLAY.
PAUL, CHRIS, YOU GUYS READY?
>> I'M GOOD.
>> HEY!
>> ALL RIGHT.
SO LET'S WATCH.
THIS IS THE WORLD'S FIRST
BORDERLANDS 3 CO-OP LIVE STREAM.
TAKE IT AWAY, PAUL AND CHRIS.
>> AFTER YOU.
>> ALL RIGHT.
I'M GOING IN.
A BUNCH OF ENEMIES OVER HERE.
I WILL HEAD ON THE RIGHT SIDE
AND TRY TO SPLIT THEM UP.
I SEE A COUPLE BEHIND THEM.
POP A TRACKER.
>> SWITCHING OVER.
>> NICE SHOT.
>> TAKING OFF SHIELD.
SWITCHING TO FIRE.
GROUND PLAN.
>> YES.
>> ONE ON THE LEFT.
WAR PACKER IS IN.
GRENADES ON THE CROWD, RAIN.
>> UP AND OVER.
>> ALL RIGHT.
AND YOU HAVE ONE THERE.
>> CAN YOU --
>> MISS MY DOOR.
HIT THEM WITH A GRENADE.
HE'S DOWN.
>> NICE.
>> THAT WEAPON DEPOT ISS A JUICY
TARGET.
THEY HAVE FORCE FIELD AROUND IT.
IF YOU SOMEHOW CRACK IT OPEN,
YOU WILL FIND SOME QUALITY FIRE
POWER IN THERE.
>> SO YOU HAVE JUST HEARD FROM
AURELIA.
WE PASSED HER INTRODUCTION AND
SKIPPED AHEAD.
TRUST YOU WILL BE ABLE TO MEET
AND SPEND A LOT OF TIME WITH
AURELIA.
AS YOU EXPLORE PROMETHEA AND
OTHER AREAS IN BORDERLANDS 3.
AND YOU READY TO FINISH THE
FIGHT?
>> LET'S GO.
DO IT.
>> I'M GOING AROUND RIGHT.
>> ALL RIGHT.
THROWING DOWN THE SHIELD.
>> COOL.
GOING TO SWING INTO THE SHIELD.
TAKING OUT SHIELD FOR YOU.
>> YEAH.
PICKING IT UP.
>> SWITCHING.
>> TRACKING.
>> PULL THEM ALL IN.
NICE.
WE HAVE A BIG CROWD ON THE LEFT
HERE.
>> SWITCH TO SHOTGUN.
>> FLASH SHOOTER.
GO FOR THE PACK.
>> I HAVE THIS GUY.
>> WE HAVE TWO MORE OVER THERE.
NICE.
LAST ONE.
HE'S DONE.
>> NICE.
>> A CHEST BACK HERE.
>> SEE WHAT YOU GET.
>> ALL RIGHT.
GOT A LEAD OFF PISTOLS.
>> IT IS LITTLE OP.
BUT YOU GUYS CAN SAVE IT.
>> DELAYED FIRE MODE.
THAT IS COOL.
>> READY TO MOVE ON?
>> ALL RIGHT.
[APPLAUSE]
>> WOW!
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE] THANK YOU,
GUYS.
WOW!
>> I DON'T KNOW IF ANYBODY GOT
THAT MATH JOKE, DIVIDE BY ZERO.
>> THEY GOT IT.
>> WHAT ARE YOU GOING TO DO?
LOOK.
WE CAN'T WAIT FOR YOU GUYS TO
PLAY THIS MASSIVE GAME FOR
YOURSELVES AND DISCOVER WHAT-OTS
AND LOOT AND PLOT TWISTS AND
EVERYTHING THERE IS TO
EXPERIENCE AND EXPLORE IN
BORDERLANDS 3.
>> SO TODAY, BASED ON THE TIME
THAT WE HAVE, WE HAVE JUST BEEN
ABLE TO SHOW YOU A TINY FRACTION
OF THE GAME.
AND SO WITH THAT I THINK THAT
WHAT WE WANTED TO SHOW A LITTLE
BIT MORE OF THE BREATH WE HAVE.
WE PREPARED A TRAILER FOR YOU
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
>> THANK YOU, GUYS.
THANK YOU.
WOW!
THANK YOU, GUYS.
OH, MAN.
>> OH, THANKS.
OH, WOW.
I DON'T THINK THAT WE HAVE EVER
SHOWN THIS MUCH OF A GEARBOX
GAME BEFORE, OR SOON AFTER
ANNOUNCING IT.
THE FACT IS, WE NEVER HAD THIS
MUCH TIME TO FINISH AND POLISH A
GEARBOX GAME BEFORE.
WE ARE FEELING REALLY GOOD ABOUT
THE POSITION WE ARE IN.
EXCITED TO BRING BORDERLANDS 3
TO THE WORLD.
AS YOU CAN PLAINLY SEE, WE HAVE
MADE A COMMITMENT TO WHAT
BORDERLANDS IS SUPPOSED TO BE.
WE MADE A COMMITMENT TO THE
STORY, THE STYLE AND THE DESIGN
THAT OUR FANS HAVE TOLD US LOUD
AND CLEAR THAT THEY CHERISH AND
WANT US TO PRESERVE IN
BORDERLANDS 3.
YOU KNOW, IT IS AN INTERESTING
TIME IN GAMES RIGHT NOW.
THERE ARE ALL KINDS OF PEOPLE,
MAKING ALL KINDS OF MONEY AND
INTERESTING STUFF OUT THERE.
WE JUST LOVE VIDEO GAMES.
WE THINK THAT VIDEO GAMES IS
SUPPOSED TO BE FUN.
WE LOVE BORDERLANDS.
WE WANTED TO MAKE SURE IS THAT
WE WERE TRUE TO WHAT IT IS.
AND IF YOU WANT TO PLAY
OFF-LINE, WE GOTCHA.
IF YOU WANT TO PLAY ON-LINE, OF
COURSE, ALL OF THE MODES ARE
THERE.
WE ARE GOING TO DO SOME KICK [
EXPLETIVE ] DLC AND ALL KINDS OF
FUN CUSTOMIZATIONS LIKE HEADS
AND SKINS.
NOT MICRO TRANSACTIONS, NOT ANY
OF THAT NONSENSE.
[ APPLAUSE ]
AND IF YOU PLAYED A BORDERLANDS
GAME BEFORE, WE EXPECT YOU TO
FEEL RIGHT AT HOME.
BUT WE HAVE MADE SURE TO DESIGN
BORDERLANDS 3 IN THE STORY AND
GAMEPLAY AND EVERYTHING SUCH,
THAT THIS IS THE PERFECT ENTRY
POINT FOR ANY GAMER THAT IS
GOING TO BE EXPERIENCING
BORDERLANDS FOR THE FIRST TIME
WHEN BORDERLANDS 3 LAUNCHES ON
SEPTEMBER 13.
AND WHAT YOU HAVE SEEN TODAY SO
FAR, IT IS REALLY JUST
SCRATCHING THE SURFACE.
BORDERLANDS 3 IS MASSIVE.
IT IS BY FAR THE LARGEST
BORDERLANDS GAME THAT WE EVER
MADE.
WE JUST HAD AN HOUR TO TOUCH A
COUPLE THINGS NEAR THE BEGINNING
OF THE GAME.
WORKING CLOSELY WITH OUR
PUBLISHING PARTNER 2K GAMES, YOU
CAN EXPECT TO SEE MORE AND MORE
OF BORDERLANDS 3 THROUGH THE
SUMMER UP UNTIL THE LAUNCH ON
SEPTEMBER 1.
WE ARE PLANNING TO SHARE MORE
AND MORE OF THE GAME AT
UPCOMING SHOWS.
AT E3, GAMES CON IN GERMANY,
PENNY ARCADE EXPO, CRASH
GUARDIAN CON IN ORLANDO.
SO THAT SHOULD BE FUN.
AND WE ARE NOT EVEN FINISHED
TODAY.
IN THIS ROOM WITH US, WE HAVE
BROUGHT 200AMD POWERED MACHINES
WHERE YOU GUYS ARE GOING TO ALL
HAVE A CHANCE TO PLAY
BORDERLANDS 3 YOURSELVES.
IT IS GOING TO BE AN UNGUIDED
EXPERIENCE.
WE ARE GOING TO DROP YOU IN
PROMETHEA, DO WHATEVER YOU WANT.
MAIN LINE QUEST, SIDE QUESTS,
JUST FREE PLAY, RIGHT?
WE ARE GOING TO GIVE YOU 90
MINUTES.
I KNOW THAT ALL OF YOU GUYS ARE
STREAMING TO ALL OF YOUR
FOLLOWERS.
SO HAVE FUN.
WE WANT YOU TO HAVE A BLAST WITH
IT.
IF YOU ARE WATCHING THEM ON
TWITCH, IF YOU ARE WATCHING
THESE GUYS PLAY ON TWITCH, BE
SURE TO TAKE ADVANTAGE OF THE
CUSTOM BORDERLANDS TWITCH
EXTENSION, IN GEARBOX.
LINK IT TO YOUR SHIFT ACCOUNT
AND START COLLECTING BORDERLANDS
3 LOOT TODAY.
AND THAT IS GOING TO BE WAITING
FOR YOU WHEN THE GAME LAUNCHES
ON SEPTEMBER 13.
NOW IT IS GOING TO TAKE PAUL AND
THE REST OF THE GEARBOX GUYS A
FEW MINUTES TO GET EVERYBODY SET
UP ON THE DID STATIONS OVER
THERE.
SO PAUL IS GOING TO GET GOING ON
THAT.
AND I AM JUST, JUST SO GLAD THAT
WE ARE HERE TODAY.
THAT WE CAN DO THIS.
THANK YOU GUYS SO MUCH.
BY THE WAY, WHILE THEY ARE
SETTING UP, FORTUNATELY, WE HAVE
THE FOLKS FOLKS FOLKS FROM KIND.
THEY SEEN BORDERLANDS 3 HERE
FIRST TIME AT THIS EVENT.
I WILL SAY GOODBYE FOR NOW AND
KICK IT OVER TO GREG, ANDREA AND
FRAN.
THEY ARE GOING TO SHARE THEIR
THOUGHT FORCE -- THOUGHTS FOR
BORDERLANDS 3.
THANK YOU FOR COMING AND BEING
WITH US.
I'LL SEE YOU SOON.
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE] CHEER